here's here's Jimmy Kimmel's tweet to
Elon Musk he wrote it has been
interesting over the years to watch you
Blossom from the electric car guy into a
fully formed piece of [ __ ] and then he
retweeted a tweet by Elon Musk now I'll
get to the Elon Musk tweet in just a
moment but since Jimmy Kimmel is calling
people a piece of [ __ ] we went back into
the archives and we found this well
here's Jimmy Kimmel doing blackface Karl
Malone
sometime at night Paul will look up and
sky and say what the hell going on up
there the UFO live on other planet
owning home like E.T that is not just
blackface that's full black body like
you are in and committed to it at that
point now that was Jimmy Kimmel
obviously uh whatever that is 15 20
years ago or so on on The Man Show and I
think it's one of the reasons that he
went so woke because he has to do a tone
for his sins but it's not like we could
find another video of him basically in
blackface also making fun of a very fat
woman would that be possible
[Music]
my body is my temple that's why I start
every morning with a Brisk aerobic
workout
but I can't do it alone workouts are
easier when you have a partner
my workout partner is my maid Marguerite
Marguerite soft brown stomach protects
my knees and ankles from unnecessary
wear and tear nothing much longer me so
bro okay
can't even shut up in Spanish
wait
a lot of blackface with this guy also
seemingly making fun of the Latina
housekeeper uh so when you're talking
about the piece of [ __ ] Jimmy uh perhaps
a mirror would be in order uh Elon Musk
responded to that tweet with a uh
the point is he doesn't care so now why
am I mentioning all this am I talking to
you about this because it's so important
that Elon Musk got into a fight with
Jimmy Kimmel no that is not the point
the point is the narrative is collapsing
because what is it now I'll show you
what is it that Elon Musk was tweeting
about in the first place that elicited
such a response from Jimmy Kimmel well
it was a response to a Hillary Clinton
Tweet now you'll see how this whole
thing comes together we're weaving it
together for you here's the Hillary
tweet the Republican party and its
mouthpieces now regularly spread hate
and deranged conspiracy theories it is
shocking but not surprising that
violence is the result as Citizens we
must hold them accountable for their
words and the actions that follow
Hillary tweets that thing out and then
Elon just responds to it and says
uh there is a tiny possibility there
might be more to this story than meets
the eye and then he uh referenced a
website there and that's when Kimmel got
in on it the point being that something
is Shifting here in the old days and
when I mean the old days I mean
literally last week if the narrative was
out there that the Republicans are
racist and bigots and conspiracy
theorists and all that there would be
almost no way to push back on them
because you would get censored or Shadow
banned or your views depressed or
whatever whatever algorithmic trick is
involved but now Elon owns Twitter and
not only does he own Twitter so he's
allowing people to say what they want
um but he's also getting involved in it
himself right that may not actually be
the wisest thing like maybe he should be
cooling it off a bit but he's he's
poking the Bear right now and perhaps
the bear needs to be poked